check this out dozens arrested carried
away in handcuffs after protests in
Beverly Hills huh yeah because they're
coming for the suburbs they're coming
for your homes that's like the st. Louis
couple there I think the organizers know
they want you to feel unsafe in your
house they want you to bend your knees
to get in your knees and beg you know
you know the st. Louis couple actually
published a letter up according to one
of the local journalists supporting the
protests and blaming white people I kid
you not literally blaming white people
that's I mean that I don't know what I
don't know who they saw that yelled at
them and made them their life or their
lives
come on I don't know I died okay you
ever see that video ten hours of walking
in New York as a woman yeah totally
doctor do you know about the the crazy
controversy there updated afterwards
about racism yeah there cuz he was asked
why is it that everybody in the video
hollering at women is black and then he
was like oh actually I ended it out all
the white people I kid you not
that's what he said seriously yeah of
course good doesn't look good and and
for what read I don't know exactly what
he said his reasoning was but this is
this is these people are are con artists
man it's a gimmick it's a ploy and I
often tell people like on the Left my
friends
like not super ugly politically active
ones who do you think benefits the most
from everything that's happening right
now
corporations white people okay so who's
leading these protests white white
people as a statement I I don't I don't
like that I don't appreciate that
because I mean I'm a white person and
I'm not gaining anything from this stuff
this is makin America burn down I don't
like it well it's like why corporation
white identitarian ISM so like are in
charge of everything sure maybe if you
if you say that it's racist to have
minority mascots and you get rid of all
these minority mascots but we mention
this before like mr. cleans fine and
he's like a bald white dude yeah I think
those are ridiculous Uncle Ben's rice
was awesome I would see Uncle Ben's face
and I'd be like mmm wholesome rice I'm
gonna get some of that cuz I know it's a
good product and so like what does that
have to do
with race so it's all put its way why
Pleasant living man are benefiting the
most remember than the left is doing
okay sure they and left supremacists
no they're benefiting what are you
talking about I it depends on what
happens in November for sure because the
argument is that the riots are going to
make the sound majority vote for the
right and you're gonna get more
nationalistic right-wing I'm not saying
Trump is a white supremacist anything
like that I'm saying it's not benefiting
the left it's gonna potentially help
Trump get reelected so when you look at
the what the left is actually engaging
in the end result is a benefit for white
supremacists hmm and that's what
horrifies me the most because you look
at that video where the 10 hours of
walking through New York is a woman yeah
what does the guy do for whatever reason
he had it's the white people out I don't
kid yeah because these people in my
opinion are white supremacists or at
least they have a backwards ideology
where they don't realize how you know
what they're doing is it's like maybe
they're being useful idiots I have no
idea get this whole catcalling thing in
itself is stupid
because it's like what happened what
before there was tinder what did you do
when you saw an attractive person Hey hi
find you attractive can I speak to you
no well so so I mean sure there's
different levels of and and there's a
line that suddenly you're gross and you
could you don't have to cross that line
at all but that's how people used to get
together I find you attractive the line
really is if you personally are
attractive yep oh is that it the line
change if you're attractive the fact you
can you can cat call if you're not
you're gross in varying ways gusting so
if you're like your ear if you're six
foot three you know tall dark and
handsome chiseled rips you know deep
blue eyes that's a so you know me for
example you could probably say you
probably some pretty messed up things to
women and they'd be like they'd be into
it they did that on tinder they didn't
experiment yeah whoa oh yeah oh my
goodness I didn't do an episode on this
I mean we did we talked about this in
our earlier episodes it was bad but what
speaking specifically about physical
world and catcalling yeah if you are a
45 year old overweight short guy with
your belly hanging out while you're like
you know sitting at work and you're like
hey girl
what up they're gonna be like oh no
thank you but if your dad bods are in
right now
as it shows you're fiscally comfortable
if you're you're a fit listen in that
video they this is where the skate like
the scale of like absurdity starts
coming in where they start saying
everything is bad so what like
masculinity is a good thing
talk to toxic masculinity fine but now
every mask like everything masculine is
toxic yeah that's true so this is what
happens with catcalling
right you have in that video a guy being
like how's it going right and they're
like how dare are you goodness sakes I
am so so offended
yeah how I am yep like what one guys
like have a nice day yeah ma'am
so yeah like you're right like how were
you supposed to meet somebody before
tinder you'd be walking down the street
you might see before and you'd be like
pardon me miss my name's Tim nice to
meet you that is literally how I met my
wife ice i i'm not joking at all i met
her i was working at a store she came in
and I was like Hello and we talked for
two hours in the store it like I was
clearly enduring she was clearl into me
it matched and that's what happened boom
boom now you make but it's it's true
it's like that like they walked out the
store they went to Vegas
yeah got married yep know what it's like
there needs to be some sort of man we
need thicker skin where what happened to
all our being faced and rage man it's
baked out like in that video when
someone says like come on have a nice
day ma'am like out there we go it's like
are you just being upset because you're
you're looking for things to be upset
about yes Lydia agrees yeah it's it's
it's boredom you know it's boredom it's
I think it has to do with people wanting
to feel powerful yeah and that's why
we're just simply having a purpose and
and you know going online and having a
lot of people go I'm with you I'm I'm on
your side here how dare all these people
and then all of a sudden boom they have
you know it's a great recruiting
technique a cult recruiting technique
that's that's that's POTUS called
love-bombing they surround you and they
hug you and they love you and they make
you feel validated
I don't know what video game this was
maybe you've played it where the
difficulty settings are like it's like
normal hard very hard easy and I had a
hard day at work I just want to feel
powerful
I kid you not like I came from which
game this was maybe you guys listening
might know I'm talking about something
like that oh my goodness no no that's
fine it's like you want to play a game
where you can just be the the demigod
with you know laser laser beam eyes yeah
and you go around and you like I played
GTA and I put on the cheat codes and I
jump super high and I punch people and
it's like you just play G it's fun yeah
you know it's it's it's just you go
around riding your dirt bike and jumping
in the air and crashing sometimes people
just want to play games so they can feel
powerful that's a good point what
happens when people don't have that
outlet and they don't feel if you'll
powerless it's it's like you know
there's a trope about the bully at
school is actually being abused by his
dad yeah yeah like the bully will be
picking on some kid and then he goes
home it turns out his dad's picking on
him and so he reading it out yeah that's
what that's what everything everyone is
doing you're right they're at home
they're powerless everything sucks they
feel miserable they're purposeless even
though life is better than ever you know
and so they take it out on you well they
don't have to work for the things that
you used to be hard in life you know
nowadays the the hardships that we deal
with you know is like putting enough
well I mean work you have to work for
food but it's like what do you what are
the hardships or we're worried about
what people say about us online people
are banning for like that person said
something that really hurts me to the
core because four generations ago this
happened to me and it's like I mean that
you could apply that to anything anyone
can get upset think about what so so
reddit is banning a bunch of people
mm-hmm
think about what that sites gonna be
like when they just keep banning
everyone who's offended by anything you
are allowed to say the word da well
who's this is what I'm wondering like
who goes there anymore you know I I was
actually shocked to find reddit was so
prevalent still and I don't think that's
gonna last very much longer
because I I agree yeah I mean Facebook
even you know it's like over almost
twelve hundred comments over a thousand
of them said no of my tweet asking if
Facebook got deleted would you care
would you be upset
I wouldn't everyone was like no I go on
Facebook nowadays half of the posts are
anti-trump stuff being restated and I
like look into it and it's all not
true it's all homey and I asked like hey
where's your source this is my source
didn't you not see what I just posted
it's like did you read it it's no listen
straight up that's what they say to me
no I didn't read it I just reposted it I
know it's true because it's a man who
replied to Trump a minute after Trump
tweeted therefore that's my source and
and this is this is the best part I
someone was like you know that's not
true I was just reading and they're like
yes I know and I don't care yep what's
right so you know it's it's fake and
you're just using it to further your
anger that you're addicted to we have a
we have a mutual friend and do we I'm
sure we have more than a few friends Tim
they posted something about one of the
riot incidents okay and I innocuously
just gave a timeline I didn't say they
were right into the wrong uh-huh I said
1 2 3 4 5 and they flipped out turns
screeching and I'm like oh I didn't even
say I disagreed with you like I don't
know for mutual friends anymore yeah
these people are crazy they're there
they're rigging I know who you're
talking about
probably yeah I mean by I think I know
exactly I know I know you know I'm
talking about and they post something
and I'm just like ah so here's what
happened how dare u post facts Emily is
that what you're really mad about I
didn't say you were wrong and then and
then and then when people started
chiming in saying this doesn't justify
anything I'm like never said it did I
love that and then I respond with you're
completely right this guy's out of line
and we should absolutely condemn this
and then all of a sudden they just like
their brains explode and they're like
I'm walking you I'm like why are you mad
at me I don't understand like what am I
suppose it's because it's an emotional
trigger that's what happens to them the
more you lean into logic the more easy
it is to understand the truth to say the
truth you don't have to remember fake
stuff and then you know the facts
support the truth and and that makes it
easy to talk to people about what's
actually happening but they don't want
to deal with that that's too much it's
so much easier to just go
yeah I think emotions I think handle
though who are unwell I yeah you're
right
yeah you're absolutely right no crazy
yep you know it's like growing up out
the the the trope was that it was the
religious right that behaved this way
that's cuz it was then yeah
and now anymore yeah now it's emotional
intelligence yeah you know it's it's
interesting I have a friend who's who
you know he goes to church and he was
telling me you know he's doing this this
outreach program and it kinda has to do
with church but it's it's not it's just
held at the church is basically just
like him and another bunch of dads get
together and all the the young boys that
don't have dads go and they like talk to
them and just do like a you know a dad
program and I was like that is that is
so legit like I'm not the most religious
person myself but like that's some
seriously amazing stuff that we need to
bring to communities and it's like why
are we doing that you know let's bring
them back did I ever tell you the story
about how they're doing something right
my opinion on Jesus changed I'm not sure
I may have done in the early months but
I think I'll rehash it just now because
probably we have way more viewers and
stuff but uh I grew up Catholic okay I
left Catholic school at the end of fifth
grade went to public school sixth grade
immediately just start like became very
atheist yeah you know ish I ya know if a
is the right young punk Tim agnostic is
probably a better word but I was totally
out of all the religion stuff and then I
started becoming very angry and like
arrogant about you know the world I
thought man I was like 17 18 if everyone
has that face yeah I knew everything
everyone and so there's this dude in
Chicago who was like moderately
well-known in the in the in the top-tier
Chicago skate crew whatever and I was
skating at one of the parks in Chicago
and I got introduced to him he was a
cool dude and we've a few people in the
park so we were skating we were talking
it was me and a couple other people and
then he was like you know I play music
and he's like yeah me too like you want
it you want to go jam or something hang
out and I was like yeah dude awesome I'm
like I can take out these cooler or like
older guys escape boarders like you know
connected and affiliated and and we go
to his apartment and in his house on the
wall he's got a picture of Jesus okay
and I was like
my picture of Jesus on your wall and he
was like I don't know I like it and I'm
like what do you mean like you were
religious or something and he goes no I
I don't know I just you know I thought a
story about a guy who traveled around
helping people was kind of cool and I
went oh you got a good point actually a
good story yeah that's kind of what I
was alluding to because it's like you
don't have to be religious you don't
have to believe everything that they say
but morally they're doing a lot of
things that make sense it's like what's
wrong with with having something that
shows you how to be a good human being
and that was it what happened to that
the realization was kind of like
everything that I thought the religion
was was irrelevant because the only
thing that mattered to this dude was
that yet a story about a guy who
traveled went about helping people you
know and I'm like if that's all he took
from it that probably made his life way
better
yeah probably helped a lot of people and
he's right yeah exact ol story yeah I
think because of the politics of
everything and the church and how money
was handled and stuff like that it
became a very political and corrupt
thing to me and I never actually thought
about what the root of what it was
supposed to be was yeah I'm still not
religious or anything but I think you
know from that moment there was there
were some other key moments in my life
where it made me like rethink things and
with that one I was like you know there
are some people who are very much into
reading hard line like here's what it
says here's what must be done
and this is this is exactly what it
means no questions asked I think from
that point on I was like that is a cool
story that's the only thing I care to
take away from it any of it right now
that I can I can straight up be like if
you just tell it like this like this
dude went around helping people healing
people feeding people like you can
ignore all the bad stuff and just say
let's try and be good people yeah let's
try and help people you know there's
some other moments too about perception
and reality that I found really
interesting I think a lot of people
don't understand I was working when I
was working at O'Hare Airport I had one
of these older guys he was a Hispanic
dude very religious guys and he was like
one day this dude goes a pool and I look
I'm like yeah it's um I think I was
playing I'm like snake on my Nokia
he's like you religious at all and I was
like nah this was this is after like it
because now I was like 19 I think okay
and I was like no I was like I grew up
but I'm not I'm not you know I don't
follow anything and then he's like let
me ask you some questions we had a
conversation and the gist of it was
basically you know he says what are you
breathing right now
and I was like what air and he was like
yeah yeah but what is it and I'm me
being you know smart about it I'm like
you want to talk about the composition
of God it's actually mostly nitrogen and
a small portion around 21% or so is
oxygen and of course come back side and
he was like yeah yeah I get it I get it
do it he read your books right and I was
like yeah and he goes how do you know
that it's actually oxygen nitrogen
whatever okay and I was like we learned
it in science class man I went to school
and he's like and you and you should
believe what's in those books and I was
like yeah because it's science and he
was like all right so you got somebody
who told you read this book that's the
truth and I was like right and he goes
yeah that's that's that's what my preset
about the Bible and I started laughing
and I'm like I get what you're saying
dude I I hear you his perspective was
basically like we all choose who we
trust and who's giving us the hard facts
yeah now for me I'm like I can actually
build a computer so I'll take my you
know I'll trust in the root of my
science and stuff like that I'll believe
in the oxygen but it's a good point
about you know I've never seen an oxygen
I've never seen an electron I've never
actually used an electron microscope
I've never actually tracked any stuff
down right supposedly there's no such
thing as solids even though this wood
feels pretty solid but technically it's
a bunch of atoms and they're really
really tightly wound together so I'm not
I'm not saying this to try and tell
anybody that this proves or disproves
anything I'm telling I'm just telling
you this is because it's a way to
understand how people's perspective our
perspectives are shaped based on what
they choose and who they choose to trust
and ultimately it's who you choose to
trust yeah if a dude came out of the sky
floating and he gave a cell phone to you
and he said here's how it works
the magic of my love will transmit any
of your thoughts to anyone else who has
my love you saw a dude flying you'd be
like wow okay you know like if you're I
can like you know a primitive or like
you know ancient culture whatever and
you saw this happen yeah you would just
believe them like basically the what the
Anunnaki or suppose I love energy
transmits thoughts and
and then if you if you would just be
like this person clearly has some kind
of power I don't understand yeah it must
be true well you might not necessarily
just absolutely trust them but you
probably believe it right yeah and so if
you get like a a PhD physicist who comes
out and says did you know that if you
you can take your hand and you can
actually hit molten steel you don't know
that you have seen it yeah you actually
can do that most people are gonna be
like that's crazy you can't do that
you know what I mean until they see the
video okay right so there are certain
things you are willing to trust based on
how you've you know perceived the world
and stuff like that and so that's why
you have you know I can wrap this back
up into the insanity of the woke left
yeah as more and more of our media our
advertising and our social media is
dominated by this ideology it's becoming
law it is becoming reality and then they
tell you you can see racism in
everything and everywhere and people
will just eat it all up
that's all they see and it's scary
because and they become rage monsters
they're always angry you know they're
always just fervent zealous fanatics and
they gonna attack people they break into
people's private property they try to
burn buildings down just because they
choose to believe this this fringe you
know nonsense yeah
critical thinking sales man thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune into this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you